et là vous avez la bugatti complètement
réalisées en lego c'est très très très
impressionnant
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est au mondial de l'auto
à paris l'idée effectivement c'est de
venir voir un petit peu les différentes
tendances voir ce qui se fait par ce que
nous proposent les constructeurs pas du
tout de faire un focus sur les
différentes gammes les différentes
nouveautés de chaque constructeur
pour cela je vous invite à aller voir
les médias spécialisés ça sera cool
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de
voir un peu les produits d'exception on
voir un peu les trucs qui nous font
rêver les voitures qui nous font rêver
comme moi qui me faisait rêver quand
j'étais gamin et qu'aujourd'hui on peut
voir sur des salons comme ça
donc là on est dans un pavillon je ne
sais pas quel numéro pavillon 4 en au
pavillon 4 derrière moi vous avez odile
qui est juste là et il ya porsche
là bas je vois au loin skoda honda
toyota on va les voir un petit peu ça de
plus près regardez c'est merveilleux
véhicule et puis on se fait rêver c'est
un petit peu l'idée on va regarder un
peu ce qu'il ya et on en prend plein les
us et coutumes regarder ça là le
roadster bmw complètement ouf on est sur
une partie électrique ici alors après un
petit tour directement sur le stand du
constructeur pour aller voir un peu les
a et les nouveautés voir les produits là
vous avez c'est pareil le x3 version
électrique
c'est vrai qu'ici ce qui est ou ce que
les stands sont juste énormes là vous
avez ici de ce côté là le stand de
jaguar regardez-moi ça alors je suis pas
un hyperspace de jaguar mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est juste incroyable
c'est tout l'intérêt d'un salon comme le
mondial de l'auto voyez les véhicules
que vous ne verrez strictement nulle
part ailleurs regardiez - ce truc c'est
juste officines ici on peut y retrouver
une voiture dans son plus simple
appareil là effectivement est
complètement dénudée on peut se
rencontrent un petit peu de la manière
dont ça va être construit en très
grossièrement parce que là globalement
pas grand chose à l'intérieur mais en
tout cas plutôt cool à regarder cette
manière là le stand de tesla qui attire
forcément énormément de monde on va les
jeter un petit coup d'oeil directement
alors les tesla
vous connaissez ya un voiture électrique
très haut de gamme complètement
hallucinant c'est le must qui pilote
cette boîte ces systèmes de portes ou
vendre comme ça c'est vrai que c'est
juste hallucinant trait caractéristique
de tesla
la bande de charges pour ni recharger
votre véhicule
ici énorme stand de mercedes où
effectivement vous avez toutes les
voitures
fatou les produits phares mais là vous
avez un petit modèle assez fait
exceptionnel qu'on n'est pas près de
trouver sur la route c'est un concept
car qui est juste assez incroyable
regardez moi la taille ou près des roues
j'imagine même pas l'idée d'un produit
comme ça en terme de puissance c'est
juste hallucinant
itron 55 quattro d'audi
les livraisons sont complètement
complètement incroyable une roue de audi
et ça ça vous apprendra pas mais une
roue du maudit sur une voiture
complètement nue pour voir un petit peu
le fonctionnement de l'électrique
ça c'est plutôt atypique au 10sport
forcément dans la place vous avez ici
est la audi r8 lms
alors on l'a mis un peu de travers sera
effectivement de la dynamique on devine
le carbone à l'intérieur pour
effectivement gagné en légèreté et
regarder non plus et aileron à l'arrière
voilà là c'est le grand kiff là on est
dans l'exceptionnel et juste top et que
dire ici devant ce véhicule c'est la bb
18 doyer joli hein je sais lire j'ai
c'est déjà bien pb 18,8 ron d audi c'est
pareil des cultes complètement ouf que
effectivement alors je sais pas si on
est sur un concept car s'il ya des
spécialistes je vous invite à me marquer
en commentaire mais c'est vrai que les
lignes sont complètement confie sim
véhicule à saint croyable et comme
d'habitude dans un salon de l'automobile
on a toujours à de très jolies hôtesses
qui accompagnent ces véhicules le ton
reste dans l'esprit sport avec
effectivement les voitures pour aller
secouer un peu aller faire du rallye on
va aussi parler victoire ici avec les 24
heures du mans
voyez l'un des on est dans le jus bien
là on est complètement dans le jeu avec
cette toyota hybride toyota a gagné
bravo toyota le modèle fit le modèle
plus masculin avec la bande rouge why
not
lexus lfa 1 limitless assez incroyable
site c'est vrai que là on est aussi dans
un véhicule d'exception vous voyez on
imagine l'espace intérieur surtout
regardez là il n'y a pas du tout de
poignet c'est juste au toucher est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui sort oui ou
non ça on ne le saura pas aujourd'hui et
même la vente ce véhicule est
complètement atypique
regardez-moi ça les lignes sont justes
ouf c'est vrai que typiquement sur des
véhicules là où on peut se faire le
plaisir de rêver je pense pas que ce
soit abordable pour monsieur madame tout
le monde mais c'est vrai en tout cas que
c'est très efficace et ne serait ce que
pour les petits coups sans l'intérieur
ça leur hyper confort
vraiment les mêmes les vieux modèles de
chez porsche
une voiture qui vient tout droit du
musée de porsche on a fait le choix
d'avoir un stand complètement fermé on
peut pas rentrer au peule et voir on
peut les admirer par contre d'un peu
loin
c'est un petit peu ce qui est dommage
parce que sur des salons comme ça ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est de
pouvoir aller vers les véhicules les
approcher au plus près les toucher sans
forcément les habits mais on est bien
d'accord
et là pour le coup avec cette barrière
là bas non il garde la frontière et avec
des marques premium comme porsche c'est
l'occasion aussi de ce fait rêver et
c'est vraiment dommage qu'ils complice
pas à s'en approcher davantage de cette
manière là mais voilà c'est comme ça
alors durant monde de tous et pas mal de
choses et mondiale tech on a déjà parlé
il ya eu le crs-1 vallières il ya aussi
le salon de la moto qui est là donc là
pour le coup cette année les deux
événements sont ensemble c'est plutôt
cool donc il ya aussi pas mal de choses
à voir ce côté là il ya un petit stand
ducati scrambler à l'extérieur et puis
là vous avez aussi plein de modèles
plein marque à penneteau à découvrir
donc ça aussi c'est cool on va jeter un
petit coup d'oeil ce que je pense qu'il
ya aussi ici de coste est arrivé en tout
cas moi qui suis motard je peux vous
assurer que c'est un grand plaisir de
pouvoir être là aujourd'hui
alors quand on parle de week-end on
parle forcément de marque comme un honda
qui ont ici plein de nouveautés plein de
modèle à montrer explosé mais aussi de
triomphe enfin un petit tour du côté de
l'angleterre avec aussi des motos qui
sont vraiment hyper hyper race et
regardez moi ça c'est vraiment très très
typique de triomphe bras mécanique chez
kawasaki
alors j'ai essayé de le faire avec mon
propre bras je pense qu'il va falloir
que je mange encore un petit peu de un
peu d'épinards mais bon pourquoi pas un
jour sur ce stand d'harley davidson a
effectivement là on va voir des plus
grosses bécanes richard les vous avez
des produits aussi qu'ils sont
complètement incroyable avec ça je vais
pouvoir en bouffer du bitume croyez moi
ici charles et ses traits lifestyle vous
avez la bécane nous faire une partie de
baby si vous voulez et puis après on se
finit avec une petite partie de ps4 pro
histoire de se marrer et en plus
derrière un côté rock'n'roll avec
l'ampli marshall voilà on est vraiment
dans les codes de harley est juste là le
stand de sujets qui avec aussi
énormément de produits
regardez-moi ça dans la vitrine regardez
la voix de loin là on est furent
complètement officiers là je vous emmène
dans le hall 1 alors le hall 1 salle
éole vous avez peugeot
nokia un très grand stand michelin juste
là avec une jolie porsche regard des
petites poches sympathique donc ici
c'est le hall où le côté français est
vraiment mis en avant on peut dire
renault peugeot citroën stand
complètement ouf issime avec des
véhicules dingue alors noyé les gammes
qu'on peut avoir qu on peut acheter
classiquement on peut retrouver en
concession mais vous retrouver en plus
surtout et c'est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant ici sont les véhicules
d'exception là vous avez typiquement
juste à côté de moi une alpine
donc on va faire un petit tour de ce
hall on va regarder un peu ce qui a vous
montrer tous ces voitures complètement
officines puis en train de plaisir on
est là pour ça laissez moi vous
présenter le stand de renault c'est à
dire c'est ça jusque là bas et arrière
jusque là bas derrière on va faire un
petit tour c'est un stand qui est
vraiment hyper hyper parce que j'ai déjà
lu il ya deux ans une invitation presse
sur le salon mondial de l'automobile
c'est juste à oufa l'euro reprend
effectivement un des modèles classiques
là et donner un petit côté sympa et une
femme eu un peu de l'oeil bon là on
voyage dans le temps franchement à côté
de ça vous avez des modèles très
actuelles clio scénique bon je vous en
passe et des meilleures et on va rêver
effectivement sur des concepts car comme
vous avez ici alors là l'idée c'est de
la voiture autonome on y va de toute
façon sur la voiture autonome la
législation est pas encore en place en
france mais on y arrive tout doucement
on va y arriver d'ici quelques temps et
la voyez typiquement avec ce véhicule on
est vraiment bien je vous avais présenté
un véhicule que j'ai vu à las vegas au
cs on dit c'était panasonic qui montrait
sa voiture autonome bien évidemment des
grandes marques comme renault travaille
dessus et là regardez ça ça franchement
de la gueule alors c'est du concept car
je pense pas que ça roule tout de suite
peut-être allez savoir
en attendant c'est vraiment magnifique
pour l'or va continuer à rêver chez
renault vous avez ici là son petit nom
est marc ela le z et ultimo alors me
demandez pas ce que c'est on va
découvrir son ensemble c'est un espèce
de véhicules bon je pense complètement
concept car regardez moi cet engin c'est
à usinor peu z ultimate team on faisait
du timon allez savoir
ça c'est la voiture de luxe du futur
avec bfm tv qu' en train de tourner à
l'intérieur
là effectivement je crois que côté luxe
on peut difficilement faire mieux six
sièges en cuir microfibre minibar au
fond je crois que là on est
juste au top du top vous voyez la
finition intérieure c'est complètement
dingue
elle vient coulisser sur le côté vous
avez ici la petite partie qui va se
lever la côté pilotage qui est là il n'y
a pas de pilote intérieur vous posez
vous êtes dans votre salon plutôt pas
mal concept de cartier en or on sait pas
si ces véhicules l'aviron sortiront un
jour après effectivement on est dans un
salon c'est génial mais surtout les
choses comme ça qui roulerait sur la
route ça fait la taille de deux voitures
actuelles c'est complètement dingue
c'est un véhicule pro donc c'était que
les véhicules les utilitaires du futur
là on leur en version bas ça peut être
le concept pour avoir votre petite
pizzeria peut-être votre petit bard
votre petit fast-food ambulants dans le
camion ça peut être ça la les futurs
foudre avec le relais dans le food truck
du futur made in renault juste en face
de renault on retrouve le stand du lion
le stand de peugeot le constructeur
français sont vraiment les uns à côté
des autres on va les voir un petit peu
ce qui a dû côté de chez peugeot
voici là il est des gens concept de
peugeot alors ici là il te regarde et
moi ce véhicule paris complètement ouf
issime là pour le coup on peut pas dire
que le design ressemble à ce qu'on peut
retrouver ailleurs
même le logo de peugeot qui complètement
rétro éclairé est juste magnifique
l'avant du véhicule et est hallucinant
c'est vrai même regardez-moi ses
rétroviseurs minuscule incroyable même à
l'arrière la légende incroyable et là
vous avez un petit drapeau
bleu-blanc-rouge made in france là on
sait signé griffé sur la voiture on
retrouve également le l'hybride là sur
le stand de peugeot avec la 3008 hybrid4
508 hybride les bornes de recharge
journée chez citroën dans le corner ds
vous avez la ds3 ya toutes les séries ds
on électrique a pas mal de choses et là
effectivement bon ça c'est assez compact
et si c'est très serré on nettoie faut
que ça brille
je les ai 2018-2019 sont les années de
l'hybride là on est continue toujours
chez citroën avec une fois de plus un
véhicule hybride qui tourne devant vous
de chez citroën et on va retrouver
toutes les gammes ici alors il ya du suv
il ya pas mal de choses un stand qui est
super un show super chaleureux chez
citroën est franchement franchement
c'est très très sérieuses et beaucoup
moins froid que certains autres stands
et pour le coup ça fait beaucoup de bien
quand la mode se marie à l'automobile va
vous avez une véhicule signée jean
charles de castelbajac
on sait de castelbajac aime bien les
collaborations entre l'univers de la
musique l'univers du smartphone beaucoup
d'univers différents il est vraiment
marier les styles et là pour le coup
c'est vrai que c'est bien réussi une
fois de plus on retrouve raymond n'y a
pas de castelbajac nantes passé une fois
de plus très sympa je quitte aussi la
partie lors ici il ya beaucoup de sons
il ya un son à côté qui envoie vraiment
dieu du fat suzuki de la partie avec les
véhicules de la gamme derrière on va
retrouver désormais devoir acheter un
petit coup d'oeil du jimmy j'ai mis pour
les aventuriers de chez suz aussi
appareils véhicule très très très sympa
on dirait des panneaux solaires pour
alimenter le véhicule dans une idée
toujours éco responsable on est une fois
de plus dans le côté prise en compte de
l'environnement l'automobilisme vraiment
là-dessus on le voit notamment les
problématiques de smart city en a déjà
parlé avec le mondial tech on en
reparlera notamment l'année prochaine au
sénat suite on ira à vegas mais toutes
les problématiques environnementales
autour du véhicule
on voit une fois de plus c'est l'idée de
montrer des panneaux solaires comme ça
c'est effectivement pas une voiture qui
roulera en l'état mais pourquoi pas ça
pourrait servir d'alimenter en tout cas
une partie des véhicules ça a un sens
c'est une vraie idée donc on voit les
hybrides on voit les problématiques avec
à les panneaux solaires on veut en tout
cas que on va est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vers des véhicules beaucoup
plus propre c'est en tout cas une vraie
vraie vraie vraie grosse tendance on a
vu porsche maintenant on va se diriger
vers l'écurie italienne ferrari
bon effectivement l'on retrouve notre
petit cheval ailé fort sympathique une
fois de plus alors là ça se comprend
également comme chez porsche tout à
l'heure un stand sur lequel vous n'avez
absolument pas accès on peut rêver on
rêve de loin je vous dis une fois de
plus c'est un peu dommage ce concert
normal effectivement que ces véhicules
soient pas forcément
je sais pas j'ai un peu je me questionne
parce que je me dis que de notre côté
l'idée d'un salon comme ça c'est de
pouvoir venir voir venir toucher
s'approcher au plus près des véhicules
là vous les voyez vous les voyez de loin
comme dans une vitrine de magasin ont
ils sont tous là mais c'est quand même
très très très dommage et j'étais à côté
de ferrari on retrouve lamborghini une
fois de plus ici on a accès absolument à
rien le rêve est limitée par une petite
bordure un petit mur bon dans les bois
elles sont vraiment très très belle
s'accorder sur la voiture d'exception on
a eu un partenariat avec eux au pot et
lamborghini ch pas si vos souvenirs
dans le cadre de l'opo finepix on en a
déjà parlé ya pas très longtemps là on
est chez lotus lotus on a pas mal
d'autres véhicules de l'autre côté
l'exigent cup 430 ce alors je ne le
connais pas par coeur jolie la fiche qui
est juste là j'ai triché
on a pas mal de produits de chez lotus
qui sont aussi vraiment vraiment
magnifique et là vous avez là stinger de
kial aurait voulu marquer ce n'est pas
une came ne les croyez pas c'est bel et
bien une cas la preuve c'est marqué
juste ici devant mais l'idée un peu de
ce slogan
ce n'est pas une classe et c'est de
casser un peu l'image de qui à dire on
fait des voitures d'exception la preuve
la voici
et là pour le coup c'est vrai qu'en tout
cas la voyant comme ça elle est
extrêmement bien extrêmement bien réussi
aux six voitures d'exception qu'on
retrouve pas partout c'est une morgan
alors morgan je sais pas si vous
connaissez
on est vraiment dans la voiture de
collection là sont vraiment
reconnaissable
bon on n'en trouve pas partout ça ne
roule pas partout mais voilà vous avez
ça chez vous vous êtes très heureux ou
très heureuse et là c'est complètement
lunaire c'est en fin de compte une
voiture qui est construite entièrement
oligo regarder de plus près c'est
complètement ouf issime tout l'intérieur
de la voiture est fabriqué en lego donc
vous pouvez toujours essayer de vous
balader avec par contre si vous avez un
carton et je vous garantis pas que vous
rentriez envie voilà la voiture
parlement la moins solides du monde
c'est une buvette illégaux complètement
fait en lego regardez le rétroviseur
les sièges regardez le volant c'est tout
du legos alors la seule chose qui est
pas du legos ce sont les pneus
une formule 1 100 % fait en lego c'est
franchement hyper hyper impressionnant
avec son pilote qui est juste là très
heureux qui nous fait un très grand
sourire taille réelle je vous montre par
rapport à maintenant c'est juste juste
officines on voit là pour ce tour rapide
du mondial de l'auto alors cette année
je le fais un petit peu rapidement j'a à
peine deux heures pour tout faire autant
vous dire que c'est la course qu'on peut
pas 3,3 approfondir mais pourquoi pas
dans deux ans imaginez approfondir faire
un sujet un peu plus long ça pourrait
être cool donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
que là je suis un peu speed parce que le
à vos souhaits
pour deux heures j'ai rendez vous pour
un événement d'elle pour la présentation
de nouveaux produits dell
donc voilà donc en cours en cours en
cours il ya plein de sujets coule donc
je vous invite à faire une chose pour
rester au fait de l'actu de la tech au
fait de l'actualité dans les modes c'est
bien évidemment à vous abonner à rester
connectés il ya plein de choses qui vont
arriver plein de surprises plein de
nouveautés voilà je vous en dis pas plus
je vous laisse un petit peu là dessus je
vous dis à très bientôt merci et puis
soyez sages produit sur une bouche vous
embrasse la compet la totale et à très
bientôt
[Musique]